I'm a right-handed person but for the
next 24 hours I'm gonna be a lefty I am
so reliant on my right hand and my right
foot that I don't know what I'm gonna do
when I can't use them as my dominant
side for minor tests like opening doors
brushing my teeth I'm fairly confident
using my left hand pretty well but
anything that requires accuracy or
dexterity that's where I think I'm going
to struggle
I already suck at doing makeup with my
right hand like my eyeliner takes me
like 30 minutes cuz I'm so bad I'm
making it match using my left hand I'm
gonna have to wake up like two hours
early yes I'm excited for the challenge
although I am positive it's gonna be
awful so I'm gonna write with my left
hand this is just not I don't even know
how to hold my pants on okay um I have
no strength and my fingers right now I
have a part of myself this is bad really
I'm not probably that looks like a
two-year-old wrote the sentence I don't
even know where to start crossing a T
here Oh God
I'm proud that it's legible I think you
can tell what I wrote but I also think
it looks horrendous and the hard part is
the eyeliner no makeup except mascara
put on with my left hand I hope I'm not
blinded after this come here
hmm
oh it looks this creepy taking shy
this is not working this is hard they
did it they're not totally even but
they're sisters not twins
just like my eyebrows I don't think that
actually you know I think I look like my
every other day just took way longer
than I shouldn't so I bought this new
mouse that's a bit more ergonomic but I
realized the way that shape is for
right-handed people only and using that
for a while was pretty and challenging
very slow process this is gonna take all
day which part do I have to click on the
mouse even the left and right click are
so confusing
do it
I'm actually trying my best right now
here comes the nightmare of my evening
so far not so bad I don't think I'm
doing a good job but I'm not cutting
myself which is great also this razor is
probably like a hundred years old my leg
is feeling a little bit like I might
have cut it a little so gonna go check
that out after being a lefty for a full
day I realized that I left arm a
significant weaker than my right this
was a good experience
I'm gonna go my fusing my right hand now
though the lesson here is I need to one
exercise more because I just don't do
that anyway and to like maybe experiment
with a few dunno things every day or
week or month with my left side keep it
relevant
[Music]